I think we start off with clips on Close, right? We got a clips
on Close video,
a classic.
The classic.
So, Zia the Witch shares her diluted take on the paintball incident.
So, Zena talks about a bunch of her legal issues here. And then,
yeah, this would be somewhat recent. And then we're going to
move into Darius's VOD, watch him talk about some of his legal
issues. All right. Where am I here? I don't know if I'm in the
Discord.
I don't I'm not in the Discord. There we go. Get over in here.
All right. All right. All right. All
right, watching Zena talk about her legal show. >> Get
ready with me to go to court today.
Now I have court here in Austin for a incident that was all over
the news. Obviously totally innocent, but you know how the news
is. And so >> obviously totally innocent and you know um
I no I I think we all know what happened there. >> Social
media. So, here's some context for that story is I'm a live streamer
and there was a citywide scavenger hunt where everybody took
part of and was running around the city trying to solve clues.
And I'm not going to sit here and lie and say I didn't have a
paintball. I totally did.
But like so did nine other
>> Paintball. I totally did. >> The Zena the Zena
Kubri stare goes pretty hard. Okay. What What am I supposed to
say? Am I Am I not a man with a with a heart connected to >> say
I didn't have a paintball >> to two eyeballs that love
drama? >> Totally did. >> Hold on. I need a I need
a picture. Okay, picture. Thank you. Thank you. >> But
like so did nine other streamers and basically the prize was
like $100,000. So everybody was running around and it was extremely
competitive. To make a long story short, an innocent bystander
got hit with paintball in their knee. But in reality, I was only
terrorizing fellow streamers.
And not to brag, but I'm going to brag. I have really good aim.
And on the news, there's even a clip of a streamer, a blonde,
similar to the victim, of course, running through the field who
got hit with a paintball by me, of course. But let the media
tell it, that was the innocent bystander who was on the water
on a kayak. And obviously, it's really bad that someone got injured
in the first place, you know, especially
>> I think so.
I think the thing is is if the prosecutors looked at it and thought
that the Adriana shot was what Zena was like was the person like
the innocent bystander, they might have charged her with something
cuz it seemed like she got overcharged, right? It seemed like
she got overcharged. That might be why she got overcharged was
they might have misunderstood which one it was and that person
wasn't pressing charges. >> A bystander. And one of the
craziest things about the news is they said it was deliberate
and intentional.
Granted, I've never believed the news anyway, but now I definitely
don't believe the news. So, a warrant was out for my arrest and
I spent basically a month in jail. Okay.
>> although I will say she's coping when she's like, I'm
innocent. There's definitely got to be something. It's got to
be some kind of misdemeanor that she was up there. >> Really?
I spent a month in jail because I had another case in another
county, but that's a whole different story. And now you're probably
thinking I'm some >> The other case in the other county
was definitely her beating the [__] out of MC. wild
criminal, but that's not the case either. So, for this case in
particular, of course, I got a shy bond the next day. And well,
the goal is to like not end up with like a probation thing that
I just don't need right now, especially for something I didn't
do.
>> The whole reason it even got pinned on me in the first
place was because there's this girl who's super freakishly obsessed
with me and my ex-boyfriend, whoever we're [__] on
her against. When I say obsessed, I mean obsessed. She wears
the clothes I left behind in my ex-boyfriend's
plot twist. The other case I have in another county involved.
>> That's a Is that a new piece of information? No, it's
definitely Murk. She's definitely talking about Mercur there.
Although she's leaving out the part where she >> Okay,
it's fine. >> Yes, she likes to make false police reports.
And the bystander that got hit in the leg isn't even the one
that called the cops and made an initial report. You're probably
thinking, why would she do all that? She tried to be my friend
for over a year, constantly telling me to break up with my ex-boyfriend,
all this crazy stuff. I curved her cuz she's extremely weird
and doesn't know people's boundaries. So, naturally, she goes
after my ex when we break up and they start an intimate relationship
together. And he uses her like a pawn to help harass me and my
new man the entire time. And she does it
>> I mean, that's a little bit true. There's parts of that
that are true. That's a little true. happily.
And in the end, once he's done using her like a pawn, he cuts
her off.
But either way, I'm going to court because I have two cases thanks
to these people. I'm just hoping that this fit gives innocent.
Um,
objection, your honor. I'm innocent.
I would never do something like that. >> I mean, I don't
know if it hurts, >> but anyways. >> I'm off to trial
now. Love you. I see
>> Austin police say they know who's behind a string of
weekend paintball gun attacks that left several people hurt.
>> Look at everybody just lined up. Ready? Icy, you could
pretty much pick anyone.
>> We're streaming. Sorry. Hey. Sorry. >> That's
a real worker. You almost
>> That's a real worker. You almost >> I don't
>> I adore how you can just sit >> listen innocent.
probably not >> there and record that and say those things.
It's mind-blowing to me. Anyways, I hope justice will be served.
>> Uh her saying she's like innocent or whatever, she didn't
do anything wrong is pretty crazy. Um I do think she got overcharged
based on what she had originally.
And I do think that um
that'll come down. There was like she basically got hit with
something that like if you're firing like a real weapon at people,
right? I think that's what she got charged with originally. So,
I just I would agree that she got overcharged, but that's probably
about as far as I go defending Zena there. Okay. And then the
other one was I think we want to watch the Darius VOD from earlier
today where he talks about his court cases with Zena. Okay.
Zena gave us a little bit of context. Oh, did he get rid of his
VOD? Oh, god damn it, Darius. Just let me watch your VODs. I'll
go find it. I'll go find it and we'll watch it this [__]
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Yeah, there we go. Mom's basement
stream.
Here we go. Here we go. Here we go.
>> Dude, he's back to using the straight raid starting
screen. Times must be
>> Uh, I really want to do IRL, but
I got to wait like uh
numbers and do two cents. All right. Can you not Can you not
Can I not get a kick? Can I disable that? You're not going to
th bad mic. Hold up. >> Thanks for the one kick. Thanks
for the one kick. Thanks for the one kick. Lily throwing pennies
at people's heads. You love to see it. All right, let's uh let's
see. Derry's going to talk about his legal troubles, some other
stuff
>> Doesn't feel like streaming apparently. Wants to go
IRL, but because because of his legal issues, feels like he can't.
Feels like the cops get called on him a lot of the time. >> Uh
because he was I don't remember. >> Okay, hold on. He's
already talking. >> Back to Austin.
like it's just it's a difficult >> Oh, well, it was uh
right here where we could start. I I jumped too far forward.
>> Uh I really want to do IRL, but
I got to like uh hold on and do two cents. All right. Can you
not Can I not Can I not get a kick? Can I disable that? You're
not going to say bad mic. Hold up. Oh my god. Thank you. Five
gifted. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
This is not going to be a crazy return stream because I was still
at my mom's and it's kind of just weird
uh to stream cuz there's kids in here. There's a lot of kids
in here and I don't want to put them on camera
uh just because my mom said she doesn't want to.
Uh why does he loop with every girl? That's what I'm thinking
of getting to the source of today.
I would like to know
>> Darius self-reflection stream. Oh my god. What about
me
is so
bad?
Cali 416, thank you. Am I just a talentless loser?
Is that dead ass? What's going on, Cali? I appreciate that. Cali
416. Is that Cali, too? Did you get another account or did you
change your name?
Thank you. Thank you. Off the rip. I'm getting monetary
stuff.
Y'all forgot me. Yo, little guy, please scan yourself on Sword,
too. Should I scan myself on Sore 2 for the >> I don't
want people making memes of me and my ex or me and Hannah.
>> I don't know if I can deal with that right now. Maybe
I'll wait like a week or something.
>> I know you guys are really wanted it,
>> it's so difficult, dude.
>> What is Darius famous for? Simp crash outs. And
I don't know if he's famous for simpouts. Just general crashouts,
Like it's just it's a difficult
>> time in my life. >> Can you be known for Tinder
streams when there hasn't been like a good Tinder stream in two
and a half years? I feel like at that point you just have to
give up the idea that you're known for Tinder streams, right?
>> Like I'm sorry. You can't have content you only did
for a while two and a half years ago that was only ever good
for like 6 months
>> and then you just haven't done it since. I don't think
I'm
in a mindset for memes right now.
>> I will just be your pay. >> Oh, hold on. >> Reban
Ruben donated $3. Holy crap. Did you see that rubber ducky with
the rubber dumpy?
>> Nope.
Oh, you're talking about the
No, no, no. The talking about the Darius Dance thing. Yeah. >> Maybe
we should hook up with Adriana's mom to to move on. Maybe that's
the to not start crying again. That's why I'm not trying to shoot.
That's why I'm trying to do my own thing. That's why I'm trying
to do my own thing, man. Because I'm not in a good
good headsp space right now. I got I have to think about like
So, I'm probably going to go back to
or tomorrow because I don't want to
make it seem I'm just going to I'm just going to say it cuz I
just don't care. I >> so his primary issue with going to
Austin was that people would swat his house or yeah call the
cops there try to get him arrested and he wasn't going back because
he wanted to not deal with that and he immediately says I'm going
to go back tomorrow at this time
very
interesting gambit >> I think there is a war I my lawyer
still has not I can show my text message to my lawyer my lawyer
has not said this for sure not but my ex submitted a restraining
uh complaint
to the
Austin PD saying that I was stalking her.
Uh during a scavenger hunt, so I'm waiting to see
uh what exactly is happening.
uh it looks like they issued a warrant for my arrest on the fourth,
but like >> I'm just waiting to see, you know, maybe they
issued that warrant for my arrest in error. just waiting to see
if like I don't know, maybe it just goes away. Listen, one time
Darius had a rash on his and instead of doing the rational thing
going to the doctor, he decided to just wait until it maybe goes
away. And that worked out. Who's to say it won't happen the same
with the warrant for his arrest?
My lawyer said they don't see anything about it. So, I'm just
waiting to get like accurate
information. Nobody's came over to try to arrest me. Nobody's
contacted me, which I don't. I Googled around and it doesn't
seem like they've done anything.
uh related to
like law like like the like like it doesn't seem like they've
like done anything like pursuing
me.
Uh
where are you seeing anything like that? I had some skitso go
on my Discord and like on the 27th
or 28th or so
and they just posted a bunch like it right after I got off stream
cuz I was sad cuz of Hannah uh because she was I don't remember
what's happening with me and Hannah at the time but I was I was
getting upset which
I also realized I need to never talk Listen, if you're a woman
and you have BPD
or bipolar er and you're choosing not to get medicated.
You're just like
harming
this like people. I don't know why he had to say woman there
when it's very clear that he cannot emotionally regulate whatsoever.
Like listen,
you you have to understand that this applies back to you, right?
So please show me your show me your prescription, okay? Show
me your prescription if you want to talk right now >> around
you.
the Hannah that was getting piped >> and it's just so it's
just so up.
The only way you will and this is I'm being dead serious. >> This
guy is literally like the reason that there is a protective order,
the reason that any of this is happening is
he directly in Zena's face. And so the cops charged him. He went
to jail. He had a whole thing. And he is sitting here like, "Well,
I needed that I need that person to get medicated." It's like,
brother, you're the one who did all the bad things that you got
arrested for. Why Why put this on anybody else?
>> Thank you, Josie.
>> Money doesn't help right now. But I I do appreciate
it. Is it's nice to know that you care enough and you can't do
anything. So, this is the only thing you could think of that
could help me. And you know what? Maybe it will help because
I asked Ice today.
>> Do you trip cost 14K? I've got those
>> So, maybe I'll do that and maybe that'll fix it. But
if you have BPD, bipolar, anything, and you're like a woman and
you're entering relationship
or anything with other people, you I think you're a bad person.
Like, be grateful. I am grateful. I'm incredibly grateful. >> Will
anybody in his chat point out to him the obvious here
that he is very regularly, especially with Hannah, the more emotionally
unstable partner in any
>> They clear the violent ones first. It's >> and
his partner are going on that cruise. I thought
I wouldn't know.
How would I How would I know who's going where, dude? >> That's
a little different than what he said. Pencil goat. He said something
more controlled than that. He said if you um if you're like unmedicated,
if you're not trying to get things fixed, you're a bad person.
But like for him, he like he is the more emotionally immature
and unstable person in a lot of his relationships.
I don't know why he feels like he can sit on his uh
he can sit on like a pedestal and and just throw comments down.
Seems odd. >> How would I know who's going where and on
what cruise anyone's going? I just told you. Okay. Well, I don't
I don't know that for sure. I guess ICE will tell me if
I guess ICE will tell me if uh they're going. So then that'll
obviously be something I don't attend. Your attorney will have
to call the sheriff's office or even the court and see if the
sheriff's office has received a warrant yet. My so far my lawyer
has contacted a judge.
They were at the courthouse today
and then they asked
I think a sheriff when they were in a courtroom and >> if
they both go then at least you know doing IRL in Austin would
feel safer for
>> It's not the point. I think if I'm going to do IRL,
I'm just gonna I think I think the future of my content
is for a minute is doing Tinder and meeting people and just trying
to have funny like dates.
Uh, what happened to Chicken? I don't know. I talked to him like
yesterday.
No, BPD is borderline personality disorder. I said BPD or borderline
or or bipolar.
BP, sorry. BPD or bipolar is what I said. So, yeah, I know their
difference. But I'm saying both of those have involve you changing
your feelings
and reactions and desires dramatically. And if you're not getting
medication to
properly handle those, you're probably like a bad person.
Um because that stuff like you're involving so many people with
things that like you can't necessarily prepare for you. You have
to let them know if >> I don't have to like say it too
many times. I just have every reason to believe that Darius has
one of those based on all of watching him that he has one of
those disorders. And so I really hope he's like not just casting
this out on other people and this is something he's come to after
seeking, you know, >> streaming. I mean, we've done Tinder
before. We're let people know that we're streaming. We'll find
some lady that is fine with it. So, what's the plan? The plan
right now is
I'm trying to figure it out, dude. I was going to talk about
my trip cuz I've been gone for like a month.
Um, we can't really do Tinder where my family's at because that
requires me to do IRL. It's going to dock something and I'm going
to do something stupid.
>> I'm going to see if he
>> So that way Lindsay had access to this cuz only like
seven people saw this. So one of them was Gift Luck. So Gift
Luck if you screenshotted this and posted it.
So you're
you're
Whoever he took to the playground. Wait, what? Who's the 19-year-old?
Whoever he took to the playground. That's Hannah. That's back
in the day, isn't it? That's definitely This is Hannah.
I know that's
>> Frankie, do it. I'll I'll add you to the group of people
like It's fine.
>> But you should just fess up now before I find out the
hard way. Who is that group right now? Your mom. So, I want >> Roblox.
Of course. What I wanted to do was I wanted to do uh I was going
to have literally I was just going to give somebody my Bella
box and I was going to have someone start streaming and I was
going to pay them whenever Kick pays me
to a cut.
But um
>> that's definitely against partnership program agreement.
>> I'm in the mood right now. I'm trying to figure out
what to do. Maybe I just need to be home. >> Would you
lose like his kick monotization if he did that? >> Maybe
I just need to be home.
Uh
I don't know. I don't know. Well, here's here's what my thought
process, bro. If I go home back to Austin and immediately, like,
let's say I when I drive into Texas, I just get pulled over and
I get popped on something I don't even know about
I might dead ass and abst myself, man. Like, it's just like
it's just getting like it's a lot mentally. So that's why I'm
just like I'm not scared, but I'm like I'm just not me. >> If
I if I go back to Austin and the cops arrest me for like my multiple
violations of the protective order, my crimes, like all this,
if the cops like do their job, that's a cataclysmic like
happen uh happening for me. Okay, I was going to say happen stance,
but it's a life-ending event for me. That's crazy that you would
make it so like something that's almost guaranteed to happen
is going to set you off like that. >> There. So I just
don't know.
You know about it now. Figure it out. I know about what?
I know about what? Okay, never mind. Yeah, no Texas then. No,
I should go back homeoo
cuz I miss >> Bro, people are still cooking Hassan. I I
think he's regretting not showing whatever that color was. Assuming
it's not a shot color. Okay,
dude. People are cooking us on left and right right now on Twitter.
I got I got all of my notifications popping off right now just
showing this guy
>> showing this guy getting cooked >> My and I miss
um laying in the bed that's mine and I miss I b I I spent like
I spent like dead ass like $20,000
on preparing myself for when Hannah was going to come to my house.
I don't understand what that could possibly mean. How did you
spend $20,000 in this?
What
can anyone explain? Like, okay, 20,000 on the overall vacation.
He said preparing himself.
>> Preparing himself for what is going to be there >> for
everything to last like month and a
>> Wait, he has to mean he has to mean the >> fell
for it again. I did fall for it
>> I actually did fall for it again. She She like broke
up with me. the same exact way kind of too. Just a random message
like I don't think we're actually into each other and then expecting
me to be like that's epic.
>> Same exact thing too. 3 months of
and it's just like
>> uh wait was it was it like the exact three months basically
before her next college semester started? Is that is that like
two summers out of three where she's just used you to like have
some fun times and then walked off into the sunset?
Shocking.
Very shocking. I'm pretty sure I'm correct on that. By the way,
if we go back to the original Hannah timeline, I think that was
in the summer as well and then she just off the summer. It sound
seems like she just did it again where she's just like, "Oh,
let's go do some cool." Oh, well, actually, university again.
Bye. Bye, >> Blackar. What? You do this to yourself every
single time. I can't feel bad for you anymore.
Um, yeah, but I don't think it's like a bad thing. Should we
just do like a postgame relationship review? Here's what I you
Okay, so here's here
>> Oh my god. Yes. >> Here's what I here Okay, I'm
going to explain this to you guys and Okay, I just need the woman
in chat. I need you guys to talk. Okay,
she leaked what? Uh,
okay. Here's here's the rundown. I'm talking to Hannah. I initially
start start talking to Hannah, right? I'm like, "Ah, let's just
go to this concert. Let's hang out. I miss you. We had fun."
yada yada yada, right? Everything's pretty casual. I It's her
birthday coming up.
I'm like, "Yo, you want to go out? Let me like take you.
>> It's your birthday coming up. Do you want to go on a
$20,000 vacation?" Keeping things casual. I'm just keeping it
casual. >> On a date? Or maybe not a date. I'll just take
you out. Whatever. fine. She I said maybe a date. She said, "No
date, but like I'll take you out. It's fine. I miss you. I want
to catch up with you. I haven't talked to you. You're sad, etc.,
etc., etc."
Okay.
Uh, and was this didn't he fly to Arizona or something and like
go to a basketball game or a hockey game with Rei? It was like
a basketball game, right? I I think him and Rey were at some
basketball. They were at some sporting event together. And I'm
pretty sure I think Hannah was there, wasn't she? Am I making
this up? Am I reaching out into the schizosphere, not not understanding?
>> Cuz I could have sworn him and Rey were hanging out
for like a day or two and then he was gone again.
we talked. I took her out. I took her to the Renaissance Medieval
Times. I brought her to
uh Malcolm Todd concert.
>> Oh, maybe. >> And we didn't do anything. We didn't
kiss. Maybe we hugged. It was fine. Last day of us hanging out.
I took her to the Medieval Times place. We had a good dinner.
She dressed up. I was dressed up like a knight.
Um, I helped her. I brought everything to her place. We left.
And then we sat outside and I was like, "Well, I hope I can see
you again." yada yada yada. And then I started leaving. And she
was like, "Are you really going to leave me here?" And I was
like, "All just like this?" And I was like, "Okay." So, she was
asking for me to kiss her. So, I turned around and I we kissed
and I was like, "Oh, okay. So, we're not just being friends.
So, we're just like now we're getting more intimate."
So,
fast forward.
>> Wow. So, we kiss and I'm like, "Wow, we're like kissing
right now. Wow. This is like happening right now >> to
the prison stream. She sees me being mean as to my ex or whatever
and she pretty much is like
you Darius,
like you're toxic and we live two different lifestyles. Don't
want to talk to you. Blocks me after that. Uh I pretty much tell
her I understand,
etc., etc., etc.
Uh and then we start talking and then we just say we like let's
just keep it let's just give ourselves space.
Two weeks later, I sent her like an image of like deaf tones
in Canada and I'm like, "Yo, do you want to go?" She's like, "Hell
yeah." And then we start talking again.
Then she starts being
in the
And then I was like, "Okay."
then I start reciprocating stuff. >> Hey, do you want to
go to this concert that's going to cost us like hundreds of dollars
to go to, maybe thousands? Do you want to do this? uh baited
her with money. No, she would like be like, "Oh, I'm so hungry."
Like, "I'm so hungry. I don't make that much money. I'm so hungry."
And like if a if a woman that I want to crack is like talking
about how hungry they are, I'm like, "Yeah, I'll get you some
food." Like I'm I'll buy you. >> No, no, it's not like
she I didn't bait her with money. It's like I wanted to her and
so I bought her stuff, right? so I could her like it's way different
than baiting her with money. It was like I wanted to her so I
bought her stuff when she asked me to.
>> your food then I guess like especially if they're just
in my phone just crying. So I bought her food and I did like
acts of service. You know, I'll get her like a little Door Dash
every now and then. >> I Okay. At what point At point is
this guy going to realize he was just being manipulated for money?
Yeah. At what point is he going to like just be, oh, I'm just
like a pay pee for this person?
That's crazy.
and then
I guess that like kind of
made her feel like she owed me something,
I guess. So, she started being
uh, and then I was being back, of course. And then in Canada,
>> this Lost in Space guy gets it. Oh my god, I'm so bored.
I could really use a free trip to Canada for the death. >> Well,
she comes here to Austin and then we obviously we stuff for the
first time and we get back together
like intimately. Uh, and everything's fine throughout that trip.
>> She scammed you, Lila.
>> It doesn't sound like a scam.
Why aren't your roommates? I don't know. I'm not home.
I'm really hungry, Dare Bear. I mean, if you're a girl, I'm trying
to. And you're just like, "Oh, I'm just really hungry. I'll buy
you dinner."
Like, I have no like, what's the problem with that?
It's like 20 bucks.
Should have ended it after the first
I don't know. I don't know what to say. How is he not
That's That's wild that he is like in the post game. He just
walked through these sentences and it doesn't connect with him.
What happens at all? >> Poor Dare Bear. Poor Dare Bear.
And then
uh I don't dude I don't even know. I'm trying to figure out like
where I misread a situation here cuz people keep saying I got
played but I don't think I got played.
I think I just got a product of mental >> I would want
to know how many times did he drop to her how much money he was
making. Did that happen? Was he showing off like kick receipts
for his KCIP payouts or something? Because that's just like game
set match right there.
because maybe this was really bad.
I don't think this that's what I'm saying. What? There's >> It
sounds like she was not sure about having feelings for you, but
took advantage of the fact that you knew you did. But she stalled
and accepted gifts until she decided it wasn't for her.
Yeah, but why wouldn't you just I'm going to give it like two
weeks and then we're just going to go through like a whole memoir
>> because here's my problem. >> She played mind
games with you. She doesn't know what she want and you >> I
don't care. And if >> also I think you lead with money
kind
>> She No, I would just give her like I'm not leading with
money. I'm saying okay, you want to do something? You're depressed.
Let's go do something. Here's something fun we can do. But then
she would like she would like post stuff on Instagram and then
she'd be like, "Oh, I only post stuff on Instagram because I
want you to be like possessive of me." >> When she first
blocked you, that was red >> She was a sign of what was
to come. >> Okay, so here's why I'm confused. Okay, she
would say something along the lines of like, oh, like you're
>> Is he talking about Zena? No, he is talking about Hannah,
a girl he met when he was 26 and she was 19.
Uh, maybe 27 and 19. Yeah, 27 to 19. and
he had to change his age on Tinder down to get through her filter.
They met, they hung out a little bit, she broke up with him and
then they got back together this summer and they he was basically
buying her then they met. He kept buying her then they went on
vacation together, kept buying her and then she broke up >> ever
possessive of me like >> Hammond in the stream. You can
just scroll back. >> What do you like? We're not dating.
>> She didn't match with first. That's
But then she would like
she would like she would like tell me like oh she would send
me like pictures of her
>> brother. I'm in the chat for all of those streams. Don't
tell me to club and she would want me to be like like aggressive
about it and I'd be like >> wait what would like
she would like she would like tell me like oh she would send
me like pictures of her at the club and she would want me to
be like like aggressive about it and I'd be like we're not dating.
Why the am I going to be doing that?
And then she and then but then she told me that's like what she
likes. I'm like so you want me to be like
like like
am I am I [__] like she wanted you to crash out?
I mean like dead ass. Yes. But like I'm like >> saying
he led with money but that's just the [__] Darius.
>> I got my money back. Holy X. >> You guys did cute
[__] for free too. >> I didn't even lead with
money. I just be like oh you want to do something? I want to
do it too. Let's go do it. And I got to pay for it. It's not
leading with
>> It's definitely >> read too much book talk.
>> Does anyone get what I'm saying?
That it is. It is very She wants me to
just tell her what she wants.
That's my >> I did not I did not get interest. >> I
think I I recently
>> I honestly was just shocked I got my money back at all.
So, I didn't I didn't push too much harder. I told him he owed
me more cuz he did kind of owe me more. >> I [__]
I think I [__] my chances of getting any sort of
relationship with her at all. Like I have no pro I had no problem
just hooking up with her >> the same girl three times.
>> I don't know. I have no I So my my philosophy is I have
no problem. >> You don't need that BS anyway. >> I
had no problem. Want to go on all expense paid trip to Canada?
Why not? She's depressed and I want to
>> What?
This guy's This guy's my right now. Want to go on an all expenses
paid trip to Canada? Why not >> girl the thing? And like
>> you don't need that BS anyway. >> I had no problem.
Want to go on all expense paid trip to Canada? Why not? She's
suppressed and I want a hot girl to be with during the thing.
And like like what the Yeah, I don't mind. I was I don't care
if we didn't date. I don't get I don't care.
How's No one's going to get that. Offer her a 4K purse. I almost
bought her a coach bag. Hot girl
>> at what point? It's got to click. It's got to click
at some point, right? >> Night and shiny armor to take
control type of guy. That's what that's what she wanted, but
she didn't want a relationship. So, I'm like I'm not going to
be possessive of somebody that doesn't want me.
Like, what? Like, what the [__] You want me to like
LAR? If you want me to like I don't LAR. I'm like I I am
to myself.
He almost exclusively lars 20k don't care. I mean like dead ass
like I was I was dead planning to spend a lot of money last month
on doing whatever. >> The piercings weren't if she has
too much of a pretty face. >> The piercings. She looks
cute. Dude, shut the up. She's beautiful.
>> Leave that alone. >> Maybe 20k is crazy. It wasn't
just on her. It was like 20k on like all my stuff last month.
>> Here's the thing. He can keep saying it wasn't on her,
but I guarantee you Destiny or sorry, not Destiny, Darius makes
that trip to Canada for like three grand tops. If he's by himself,
tops, they don't go out for dinners. They don't do a bunch of
like crazy. He just he he pinches a pennies. He takes like a
really short trip, saves up some money, right? Makes money streaming.
Instead, he went he didn't really stream.
And then he not only did he not really stream it,
he probably spent a whole bunch of money on like a bunch of they
didn't need. I don't know if they flew. >> But anyway,
>> pin head looking >> girl that isn't going to put
you through the mental turmoil, man. >> I don't mind being
put through mental. That's the thing. I just want
>> not not like she didn't do that. I don't mind being
put through mental torment. You don't understand it. Turmoil.
I'm okay with that. >> Mentally ill Lil Gup. just forget
about >> I mean, dead ass. Yeah, but I need to do that.
But like I don't like I like her a lot. So that's my thing.
But yeah,
so whatever. Pierc
>> if she hit you up tomorrow, you would respond. I'd respond,
but I'm probably going to be like, "Yeah, we need to have a serious
conversation on how you treat me." And if you want,
>> dude. Uh, if she here's the thing,
the real question is if she hit him up and was like, "I'm hungry."
Is he is he paying for Door Dash or not? And I think the answer
is unequivocally yes without a question. >> It just keeps
and you want like cool things. That's cool, but don't make me
be this person that you don't want. Don't make me try to like
be this possessive thing >> online. Will she file a restraining
>> No. What the [__] You can't qualify for
a restrain or just because you talk on a stream about somebody.
It's just like just like if you want to just have like a [__]
buddy, just say like, "Hey, I have a fetish and it makes me horny
when you message me this. If you could just do that, that'd be
great. But I don't just so you know, I don't that doesn't mean
I want anything more of it." But instead, it was like it was
like it was like, "Oh, I'm okay. So, we're dating." Like I had
to cut off like there was a situation where like
I was with Merc in a car and her TTS kept being like really and
Hannah was watching and I was like okay I need to make it very
clear that like this is
and I don't want this.
he was in a he was in a car with Merc and M was getting and he
was thinking about Hannah. Why is this guy laying out tape like
this? that's like going to come back to bite him. I thought Merc
was like not charging him, was trying not to cooperate with police.
Why is he trying to make it so that Merc will cooperate with
police >> because I don't I in reality I don't give a but
like I don't want to make other people uncomfortable and I like
told her to stop and that like made Merc.
But it's like that's like a relationship thing.
>> That's not just like a
>> with somebody thing. Like you're altering my life while
I get to do nothing to you. Like nothing. I get
>> I don't get to decide who you talk to. I don't I have
to just take your word for it. Whereas you get to watch my life
24/7 and you get to dictate everything that goes around me. And
you know what? I had that happen with the last X, too.
>> yeah, it seems like that's every girl you date >> while
while they were talking literally to their
>> It's almost like there are some issues with you
that like probably need to be resolved. It's almost like there's
something about you that puts you in this situation. >> What?
I didn't even know. I didn't even know that.
But I was supposed I didn't even know they had like a like a
cuddling relationship. And I did I didn't know any of that information.
But yet every single time I did Tinder content or any content,
I needed to like >> Why were you talking to Grace Thurp
last night? Did a move on to the next mentally ill girl. >> Do
you think even for a minute I would entertain Grace Thorp? [__]
>> like in a or even like a hangout way. I have no It's
like I'm like so above that now. Like I don't want to >> be
there. I thought it was funny. She looks fat. >> I promise
you if Grace Thorp hit up Darius and was like, >> "Uh,
I need to get away from my dad. I need a place to stay." Darius
would 100% open the door immediately.
No questions asked out. And I was like, "Dude, are you like good?"
Like she looks like she looks she's getting big, bro.
She's getting fat as
like no shade. Well, it is shade, I guess, but it's like obviously
you're going through something, man.
>> What did you expect? Hannah is born in 2005. Did you
expect her to be mature? I >> think it was 2003, but also
uh
uh I don't I'm not saying I want somebody to be mature. I want
when I go ahead and I take my time to carefully make sure someone
s like I spend my money. I use my emotional availability and
I also go out of my way to make sure someone's feelings are catered
to. I hope that my feelings are also catered into. And when Hannah
sends me pretty much a long text message saying we're not compatible,
which is just just it's just not true. It's just not a true statement.
That's just not She's like, and she's like, we we literally have
now gone on and off for like three years and then whenever we
hang out with each other, we have a good time. Like I don't I
don't want to be the one to dictate if I have a good time. But
you can't spend f four or five months saying I enjoyed this.
I enjoy this. I enjoyed this. And on a random Tuesday you're
like I didn't have fun at all.
Actually I didn't really feel compatible with you. And then go
on be like I don't guys. I don't do all this dumb [__]
And then immediately immediately >> you man you need someone.
>> [__] me on a second link. It's like it's
like and then be like oh we weren't compatible. This guy, this
guy's got to get to telling me more. Okay, I I get it. I get
that you don't like how Hannah with you, but I thought he was
going to get into his vacation. How he was spending his money,
too. >> Maybe it's just you. >> Oh, she doesn't have
I don't need someone to date. How are you? What you're saying
right now means she needs to date me. >> I need someone
to I need someone who is supposed to be even my cuz here's the
thing. She gave me a message saying you are compatible yada yada
yada
like her. You can do better. >> That's what she was trying
to say. But she's trying to say we're not compatible. And I'm
like, "Okay, so we're not compatible. Do you still want to?"
And she says, "Yes." And I'm like,
"Okay, so we still want to fuck." And she said she wants to hang
out when like I'm in town. I'm like, "Is it there's obviously
other problems here like, you know, I'm far away. I'm long we're
long distance. You know, I got like court cases and going on
that are
>> uh it sounds like she just doesn't really like you as
a person, as like a partner, right? as somebody she's like attached
to, but like if you're in town, you want to hang out, she's down
for that. Like you're a fun person to hang out with temporarily,
not a cool person in general for the long term. I mean, I think
pretty easy to understand. >> My life is pretty chaotic.
>> She's a looney bin. Loz,
>> she's not a looney bench. Like, I don't even think like,
dude, no one I realize only saying this is just negativity. It's
just like
I just can't message her like things that I'm upset about. So,
I'm going onto here to do it, but I realize that other people
not going to have the same perspective as me. So, I probably
shouldn't do that cuz I don't think she's looney or crazy. >> Anna
always struck me as much more stable than Bloatius. Uh, yeah.
Seemed more stable on stream and everything. Seems like she It
seems like she's just not that into him, right? In terms of like
a relationship. Pretty >> I just think she was inconsiderate.
>> Okay. Sorry. >> You can't tell her. I'm We're
block now.
We are blocked. I did I I made sure I blocked her first though
to display the dominance, but
>> I am blocked immediately after. >> Sorry, I'm
not laughing, dude. Oh my god. Hassan Raiden memes would go so
hard right now. Let's go.
Hassan is the god of lightning and thunder. Hassan's calling
th bolts of lightning out of the sky
to smite any who dare defy him. Okay, stay on your bed, Ka.
Stay on your bed.
Oh, that's really funny. Me like a day. >> Uh, incredible.
Incredible stuff. >> So, are you just upset she led you
on? Is that it?
>> I'm upset that I'm upset about the >> Did you
block AU? If you didn't, please
>> I am upset that
everything
changed in a 72-hour period.
And I'm someone who's very open to
I'm someone who's very
like I'm not like I don't get my feelings hurt like that. Like
if you're just like, "Hey, I didn't really have a good time with
you." I'll be like, "Okay, you didn't like that moment. Okay,
what didn't you like about it? We could talk about it."
But
uh it doesn't it feels like she she treated me like somebody
that we just like hung out for like the first time in a while
and then we didn't have a good time. No, sorry. We just hung
out for the first time in a while. This is like
now like
like the third time we've gone on like a trip or did something
together for a prolonged
dude. I thought I I know this is going to sound like cope. Okay,
but I swear to God, Darius is usually better at getting to the
point than this. I swear he's normally at least a little bit
better than this. It's like, dude, what what are we doing right
now? He's just said the same thing like eight times in a row.
[__] me. zombie like
>> I don't think so. >> Ka trying to get off her
bed. Uh-uh. I don't think so, Ka. I don't think so. Not happening.
Not today, Ka. >> Period of time. I like how you constantly
resize the roking window. Yeah, cuz sometimes I want to see myself
and sometimes I don't. Third time. Well, third time we were like
together like every day for like like the second time we were
together for like two weeks straight.
Just call her on a burner. I was thinking that.
So, right before she blocked me, she said she she literally
re-shared on Tik Tok a video that said
that said the video was like, "If you try to message me on other
contexts, I'll give you a third or a second chance maybe." >> Dude,
uh, >> something along those lines. >> That's a weird
That's a weird thing to
Listen, I'm going to block you on here. Message me on another
platform. >> Just got a dash or something. Maybe you're
right. Should I actually just Uber her flowers?
You never learn
to relationship. >> Who's a who's a who's a few? >> Who's
who's a who's a girl? Who's a girl in chat? Cuz here's the thing.
I don't think I understand women anymore. I'm actually having
a really hard time processing this. And I don't think I I want
to be in a relationship with anybody ever again. Like at any
sort of like does this just we're like having and we're like
never talking again. I think I I maybe do like a thing where
like I maybe I'll buy now.
Okay. I'm a girl. Okay. Let's say cuz there's a guy that you
you like him, right? You like him. Like you said, I love you.
Said you want him to like get you pregnant. All this other
uh but like you randomly decide you don't like him anymore,
right? And then you uh >> do this overord.
you you uh
tell him, you know, I I don't think we're compatible,
uh, etc., etc., etc., and then he kind of like sneak disses you
and then blocks you,
right? But it's not really that bad of a sneak diss. He just
obviously is really mad about the situation. It's not random
trust, dude. It's so random.
I know that she probably had feelings. >> I'm tweeting
some of the memes you guys >> has multiple times said that
she is uncomfortable with the with the way the relationship is
with the way the relationship is moving. Okay, so my whole point
is Okay, I'm having a hard time explaining this. My whole point
is she's commented multiple times about how she's uncomfortable
how the relationship's moving, but she's the one moving it that
way. She's the one moving it that way. She's the one being like,
"I want you to be possessive of me." She's the one saying, "I
want you to not talk to any girls and only talk to me." She's
the one having the ego trip and wanting all this stuff. I didn't
tell her don't talk to any guys. I didn't say all this stuff.
Blah blah blah blah blah. I didn't do it until she did. Like
that's like I thought that I I mean, listen,
I don't know very much. I would assume if all you do is show
you're detached and don't care, then probably the person like
if you're like, "Oh, well, it's wrong for me to tell you to do
anything, wrong for me to like care at all about anything you
do," the person probably just thinks you don't care about them.
There's like a there's a different tone you should take when
it's like, "Oh, they I don't know. It sounds like Hannah's trying
to bait him, like bait reactions from him in some way." Seems
like she's trying to confirm that you might actually care and
you repeatedly respond with, "Well, actually, here's why I don't
think you uh here's why I don't have any reaction to that. Here's
why it would be wrong for me to react. >> I'm upset. I'm
the one she's the one who's doing this to me, and I I'm like,
okay, if you don't want to do that anymore, that's okay. But
don't say it's like an incompatibility thing." just say like,
"Yeah, I think that I I don't want to do I don't want to do that.
I'm I'm upset that I was I was I was like I was I was like trolled.
I was trolled. I was only just trolled. I was trolled to make
it so that way I for me to chase her. I was trolled into chasing
someone. She wants you to obsess over her because she wants to
string you along until she finds something better. Why the do
I need to obsess over?" And >> I don't even know that that's
true. I feel like
I don't know. I feel like this person
I feel like this person had a reason they didn't want to be with
you before. They might have gotten some impression that you changed.
It sounds like a lot of the stuff with your job and how you treated
your partners on stream had to do with their hesitancy to be
with you. And then I don't know at some point in the middle of
all of the you were doing with your partners at the going to
jail and all this other something clicked and she was like oh
it's still the same. >> I Okay. So that's why I'm saying
that's why I said like I so I dissed her at the end. I was like
you deserve all your past relationships. TLDDR her last relationship
sucked. They they traumatized her. So I said yeah you deserve
that cuz like you're a like you just literally like you you did
you did you did she
you obsessing on it? Yeah. Because I just spent my whole birthday
month for my last year of my 20s with a
dude I didn't need to do that with my birthday month. Yeah, I
know that's not a masculine thing to say, but I wanted to do
a birthday month. [__] you. I'm 29 years old. I'm
going to hit 30 and it's not going to be I can't do this anymore.
>> Top Bronson very quick and combining some some memes
together. Okay, dude. I'm sorry. I'm I'm just thinking about
Hassan shocking his dog even more now. Okay, my bad. My bad.
I'm just listening to Darius rant about his relationship and
laughing. Okay. Uh,
brother just loves to chase. I don't need to chase. I don't need
to chase her. I don't need to chase her. She could have said,
"Hey, there's a guy I'm talking to. I really want to go on a
date with him."
That's okay. Go ahead. That's fine. The The thing I'm upset about
is that I got told I'm incompatible with somebody that I was
compatible with for four to five months. I settle on calls every
[__]
for no reason because we work out. What the [__]
does that even mean? Why am I doing this?
I I don't know how to tell him this.
Does he not know that people will like
uh how do I describe this? I feel like I feel like maybe Rei
could get this through to him because I feel like unfortunately
for Darius, he did something similar to our relevant at some
point where it was like, "Hey, I don't feel stable. I need somebody
to talk to to like dump all my negative [__] onto.
Right. And really got to be that for Darius for a long time.
And it sounds like Darius might have been that for Hannah. He
was describing how Hannah wasn't doing well, right? Or something
like she was really upset. And it's like it sounds like Darius
did that for Hannah
and that she maybe didn't appre necessarily appreciate it as
much as he would have liked her to. It's like but people do that.
People do that. >> Just do good. I'm moving. Action says
she's making me boo. >> She just got scared because she's
fresh out of relationship. It seems like >> Oh, is there
a loner box? Sweet. What is this one? >> She's not even
fresh, just so we're clear. But two, dude. Okay. Can somebody
explain to me why Fandy is live streaming her birth apparently?
Is this a thing that's real?
Okay, cuz there's a couple things. Hold on. What is this loader
box tweet? Oh, I sniped this from Loader Box. I sniped it from
loader box. Uh-oh.
Listen.
Close. We close this one up.
I didn't I didn't know it was a loader box suite already. Okay,
I get it. I like this one more anyway. This one's way better
anyway.
All right. Uh what are we doing? We are Oh, I there was a Misk
clip I wanted to pull up and then we could continue on with this
cuz I don't know. I saw this I saw a title today and I was very
confused. Oh, is it gone? It was like Ms. Kef tries to block
FY's like birth from happening on stream. I'm like, what
And then I found out Fandy is like live streaming her.
I don't know. Crazy. Okay,
hold on. It's literally on the front page of Kick. Give me a
second. I'm going to go I have to see what this possibly means.
They literally have her She's literally the primary featured
streamer right now. She's actually the primary featured streamer.
This can't be real. This can't be real. This can't be real. Is
that Amaranth? No, there's no way that's Amaranth. That's not
Amaran. There's no way. No, it's not Amaranth,
brother. This is The internet's actually cooked. Okay, the internet's
actually everything's cooked. She's the front page featured stream
right now.